yeah
but I can't hear a word you say
I'm talking loud
I'm criticized
[Music]
you shoot me down
oh my God you have to audition for the
fellas I can't concentrate on anything
you're saying until you cover your junk
just can consider it one time we sing
back up for Prince his butt is so tiny
but I can hold it with like one hand
oops oh
seriously
I am nude you were seeing titanium right
you know David Guetta have I been living
under a rock yeah
song Is My Jam
my lady Jam this makes me it is song
really builds
can you sing it for me
tomorrow get out not for that reason
I'm not leaving here till you sing
bulletproof nothing to lose
[Music]
shoot me down but I won't fall I am
Titanic
titanium
shoot me down but I won't fall I am
oh yeah
I'm pretty confident about
you should be
oh
you have a lovely voice
thanks
see you at auditions well I hope you all
remember the way you feel right now so
you will never want to feel this way
again Chloe your voice didn't sound
aguilarian at all
Chloe for serious what is wrong with you
I have nodes
oh my God
I found out this morning
what are nodes vocal nodules
the rubbing together of your vocal cords
at above average rates without proper
lubrication they sit on your windpipe
and they crush your dreams isn't that
painful why would you keep performing
because I love to sing yeah it's like
when my lady doctor told me not to have
sex for six weeks and I did it anyway
you should really listen to your doctor
the key is early diagnosis
I am living with notes
but I am a survivor
I just have to pull back
because I'm limited
because I have notes
Chloe this is horrible well at least
it's not herpes
oh dear I have that as well
some serious horse
what's that smell stinks everywhere I
don't want to be like the old Bellas
yeah I want to be how we are now
you should have listened to Becca
oh so it's my fault that's not what I'm
saying
no no I'm the jerk I am the girl
obsessed with winning Aubrey you're too
controlling and it's gonna ruin all of
us you know I can lose control if I want
to
I can let go
this time I'm not gonna choke it down
hmm
[Music]
we could have been champions
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
I know
I just
wanted to say that I'm sorry
what I did was a really dick move and I
shouldn't have changed this out without
asking you guys
and I definitely shouldn't have left
I let you guys down and I'm really sorry
and
Aubry if you would have me I want back
in
foreign
wait thank you that would have been
embarrassing
when we're having
fun
[Music]
it's going down I'm yelling timber you
better move
[Music]
[Applause]
here's Becca Mitchell leader of the
group look at these sequins and sparkles
their feet just don't stop moving
[Music]
up that's the way we like to work
[Applause]
you may have to do that backflip right
back over the fence into Mexico I think
she's Guatemalan oh none of that matters
there is so much happening on stage I
don't even know where to look back in my
day we put on our Blazers and we just
sang we maybe snapped our fingers and we
were feeling frisky
[Music]
oh another surprise an overweight girl
dangling from the ceiling who hasn't had
that dream
[Applause]
[Music]
all you ever did was
[Applause]
it okay she has no underwear on we have
a Commando situation there is a Commando
situation on stage oh he's on top of it
she's turning brace yourself
oh no
Garden Bellas who came here to see us
because you are what do the American
kids say jelly we are so not jelly we
should really thank you for making this
tour a reality you know with your
bumbling in aptitude we should send them
something fruit basket yum yum oh would
you prefer mini muffins
okay we didn't come here to start
something with you guys we just wanted
to check you out before the world where
we're gonna kick your ass
that's right
you
you are the kicker of ass
oh yeah
you are so tiny
like an elf or is it a fairy Sprite
you are like a troll
you are physically flawless
thank you thank
[Music]
you but we are not scared about the
worlds because when the Bellas hit the
stage we are going to blow mines it was
what more of flabby Abby's baby shoot
that's not my name I don't know your
name could be anything I'll beast and
knees inflexible Tina Lazy Susan my
number is for Amy and I eat crowds like
you for lunch
your team is like how do you say that a
heated mess you know a mess where heat
is applied to it so what once was a
little messy is now even Messier
Darlings please take my advice don't try
to beat us you can't we are the best
now I really
okay just because you were making me
very sexually confused does not mean
that you are intimidating we have
nothing to lose
we have literally not
to be the same oh what is
happening I'm using my hands so much
many times I've tried to tell you many
times I've cried alive
always I'm surprised how well you've got
my feelings to the barn
don't wanna leave you really I've
invested too much time
to give you up that easy
[Music]
whatever we deny our embrace
[Applause]
[Music]
everything is judging the size of this
Lake why don't you just walk around the
lake
but Amy doesn't do anything small yes
I've been using my shower shoes
okay I love you too here she is
what up Mrs Jones
[Music]
to start the facts
back when
I'm soloing here whatever
we belongs
[Music]
together
close your eyes and try to sleep now
close your eyes and try to dream
your mind and do your best to try and
wash the palette clean
how much we really here
I hear your voice inside me I see your
face
[Applause]
[Music]
a general Posen and I were wrapping up a
clandestine operation that I've just
come from our classified briefing
I got so you were just with aubry's Dad
I'm so excited to see your show
it's just too bad that he can't make it
totally fine huh you know he's a busy
man and my dad always said
expect finite disappointment and
remember there's always
[Music]
went down
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Checkmate Bella's checkmate
well hey
heard you all really uh lit it up last
night
Like a Phoenix Rising From the Ashes
only a really sad version where there's
no Phoenix and just ash
[Laughter]
foreign
sorry I forgot where we were in the
conversation next time when you're
trying to impress DJ Khaled
try to have some dignity uh we never do
anything with dignity so
Patricia okay all my former jelly
wrestling coach slash babysitter
do you remember me how could I forget
the girl
who gave me this you really shouldn't
have put me in a Timeout
Let's Dance
[Music]
foreign
stop your lips
[Music]
foreign